540 kilometer soll der jet für 150 passagiere
zurücklegen und das rein elektrisch so die pläne eines kalifornischen start up unternehmens bereits
2021 könnte der erste prototyp abheben und norwegen plant sogar schon vollelektrische
kurzstreckenflüge
elektrisches fliegen also jetzt schon möglich jetzt zwei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Und am ende des videos habe ich übrigens ein geschenk für euch von technology review in zusammenarbeit mit dieser quoten zeitschrift ist nämlich dieses
video hier entstanden ja der trend in der luftfahrt der ist fatal und
elektrisch betriebenen flugzeuge könnten ihn bremsen auch wenn die triebwerke immer effizienter werden und dass treibstoff einsparen kann diese positive entwicklung
das anhaltende wachstum des transportaufkommens nicht wieder gut machen und so ist man mittlerweile davon weggekommen
einzig und allein auf die entwicklung neuer triebwerke zu setzen um dieses problem anzugehen als
möglicher neuer ansatz gelten jetzt
hybridantriebe bei flugzeugen die jets für 150 passagiere
des kalifornischen startups light electric das rund 540 kilometer weit kommen soll will easyjet schon
2027 in seine flotte aufnehmen der zeitplan eines norwegischen
flughafenbetreibers der sieht das für 2040 vor und da sollen die kleinen flieger
voll elektrisch sein kleinere anbieter wollen das schon vorher schaffen wenn auch zunächst einmal mit kleineren modellen ein us start up
beispielsweise will schon in vier jahren seinen 16 meter lang wie bridget für zwölf passagiere in die luft bringen
1130 kilometer weit soll dieser jet kommen und das mit einem tempo von bis zu
550 kilometern pro stunde die betriebskosten könnten sich achtung um 80 prozent senken und zwar durch spriteinsparungen
und geringere wartungskosten der er einfach gebauten elektroantriebe im vergleich zu herkömmlichen flugzeugen sei außerdem mit
75 prozent weniger lärm zu rechnen doch nicht alle fachleute
auf diesem gebiet sehen die hybriden schon so weit vorne zumindest nicht in der nahen zukunft denn für sie sei die
batterietechnologie noch gar nicht so weit der notwendige durchbruch
dafür ließe noch auf sich warten und frank anton der chef der siemens ir kraft sparte
doch für komplett ausgeschlossen hält er die vision nicht jedenfalls
für alle bereiche außer finnischen wie den kurzstrecken transport in megacities wird es in den nächsten drei jahrzehnten keinen vollelektrischen antrieb geben
damit sind mini drohnen gemeint die kurze strecken vollelektrisch fliegen was technologisch schon komplett gelöst ist siemens dagegen
arbeitet an dem sogenannten
seriellen hybridantrieb das projekt laufe auch schon und man erwarte eine echte umwälzung der luftfahrt bis 2020 soll dem plan zufolge
ein hybrid elektrische antriebsstrang in
170 s regional flugzeug eingebaut werden und abheben
siemens zufolge könnte dadurch der lärm effektiv gemindert werden und treibstoff im zweistelligen prozentbereich
eingespart werden das prinzip sieht so aus ein generator im rumpf produziert strom er selbst wird durch eine gasturbine
angetrieben die auf kerosin läuft der so produzierte strom treibt
elektromotoren mit den rotoren an so dass die nötige leistung auf mehrere kleinere
elektromotoren verteilt wird zu finden dann an heck oder am flügel das ganz neue formen in sachen aerodynamik
und flugzeug design möglich macht die jeweilige
batterie würde je nach einsatzgebiet des hybrid flugzeugs ausgewählt und die turbine je nachdem wie viele elektrische
energie für den flug gebraucht wird beim staat würde der strom aus den akkus für einen extra schub sorgen
die batterien könnten durch die turbine dann während der flugzeit wieder aufgeladen werden
noch effektiver wäre es wenn der luftstrom im sinkflug die propeller bewegen würde und somit auch die
elektromotoren diese fungieren dann als generatoren die die batterien wieder auffüllen das kennt man von
elektroautos wo beim bremsen strom
rekuperiert wird doch dieses konzept hat nicht nur vorteile sondern auch einen gravierenden nachteil die leistung wird in form von
elektromotoren batterien und gasturbinen quasi dreimal
verbaut und das bringt erhebliche gewichts nachteile mit sich die große frage dazu lautet also können die vorteile die die verteilten
elektroantriebe mit sich bringen diese gewichts nachteile wieder ausgleichen noch kann die forschung dazu keine antwort geben ich sag mal vielen dank an
technology review in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser ziemlich coolen zeitschrift
jemand ziemlich weit vorne mit dabei ist dieses video entstanden und exklusiv für pixum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt
mich eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen link klickt das soll sich wirklich und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken so
funktioniert fliegen oder nicht da erfahrt ihr warum fliegen nicht so geht wie es im unterricht meistens erklärt wird bis dann
bleibt dran